I'm Jeff Cavista at Scoutmaster of Trude 965, Kuwait City, Kuwait.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now for you, Scoutmaster,
Here I am. I'm sitting in my chair in the campsite,
I'm having a little nap. I hear the crunching of leaves and here comes a scout.
I try to play possum for a while, but it doesn't work,
And he says I burned my finger.
And so I open my eyes and I say: well, do you have any ointment?
And he looks at me and he says: no, I didn't know I needed an ointment.
Hey, that's the way it goes sometimes, right?
Hey, this is podcast number 260.. Hey,
Hey,
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's see.
Look at the mailbag here. Kyle Burkholder is with Troop333 in Peoria, Illinois,
And he said: thanks for all the work you've been doing.
I first found your blog and podcast on my Facebook newsfeed.
Being an Eagle Scout, I clicked on one article about Eagle Scouts, wanting to know what your thoughts were,
And I was hooked on listening to your podcast.
I've gone all the way back to the beginning.
I've been listening to them all.
I'm currently up to number 210..
We're going to have a race, folks
Who can start at podcast number one and make it to 260. the fastest
Ready set go.
Kyle went on to say this past week I've been having trouble with your Android app.
Oh yes, you have Kyle, as have a lot of folks-
And I think I mentioned this on last week's podcast-
just having a problem with the Android app for ScoutmasterCGcom.
That should be resolved in a very few days.
I'm changing app providers.
I am really really sorry
And I appreciate everybody's patience with this,
but we should be up and running with the new iteration of the app very, very soon.
Over on the blog this last week we had a post about developing or training youth leaders
And I heard from Mike Rossender about that post
And he said: in your driving example-
and part of the post is an example of how I taught my steps on to drive behind the wheel
of an old standard transmission Honda Civic.
But Mike went on to say you provided some critical training. specifically,
You shared some new vocabulary that made it easier for him to understand the cause
and effect of what was going on.
While I agree training can be easily overdone,
no training at all can leave novices with no mental handles,
no easy way to get a grip on the problem.
With a little bit of vocabulary,
they can think more efficiently about their experience.
The training you provided was minimal, targeted
and delivered exactly when it was needed.
That training should not be discounted, because I strongly suspect
that tiny bits of training made the experiential discovery
even more powerful, engaging and fun.
Well, Mike, I think we probably agree more than we disagree.
Now I'm a really hard sell on event based training, simply because
I have very little evidence that it's a very effective tool for developing leaders.
I think most of the event based training- and I'm talking about
hey, let's sit down and we're going to train you how to be a leader, kind of things-
I think, if we're brutally honest with ourselves,
it's driven more by the desire of adults to explain things than anything else.
I think we're more comfortable when we can explain what's going on,
and you know, we want our youth leaders to know everything that we know
about leadership all at once while they're sitting and listening.
And we want to introduce a vocabulary to them
And I don't think that's all that helpful, frankly.
If we begin with discovering the concepts behind the vocabulary,
then they'll pick up the vocabulary as they go along,
but the definitions will really stick
because they'll understand experientially what they mean.
Now, explaining things isn't objectively bad, of course,
but I just think it's the least effective method for helping people understand
or develop skills in things like leadership.
Some explaining may be helpful from time to time-
and I think I pointed that out in the example in that post-
But experiential discovery is a much more powerful way
to begin to develop and attain these skills.
So if we take all of the things, all of the concepts and ideas
that are in our event-based kind of formal training
and we make that part of the experiential process,
in giving our scouts limited and timely explanations
as a part of an experiential process,
then all of the content of the formal training is going to be built in,
but they're going to get it exactly when they need it
as they're actually doing the work.
Everybody's mileage is going to vary on that.
I'm talking about the style that I prefer
and that's why I get to have a blog in a podcast.
But I really appreciate it, Mike, I appreciate your thoughts. I do.
Let's see. On podcast number 259, last week's podcast,
we talked about the Socratic Method
and I heard from Rob Karagman who said
Thanks for the podcast about the Socratic Method.
I used it last night while we were instructing
and the new scouts were excited to show they knew all the answers
and the older scouts were excited to show they knew it all.
So yeah, if you haven't listened to that podcast-
and the discussion of the Socratic Method-
which I won't go into trying to explain here,
but basically it's asking questions-
is all in last week's podcast, podcast 259..
We had two or three live chats this week.
It was great fun and let's see here,
In addition to our wonderful frequent flyers who show up
for live chats, we had some new folks sign on:
Jay Brant from Cherry Hill, New Jersey,
where he's an assistant scoutmaster.
Justin Sypes from Washington, Iowa.
He's the scoutmaster of Troop 242..
Richard Blackman is in Bethesda, Maryland,
who's just getting back into scouting.
He filled out his form
and he got put on the district committee right away.
Well, that'll show you right.
Randall Cox is a commissioner in Huntsville, Alabama.
Brian Frey is the committee chair
for Troop and Crew 212 in North Glen Colorado.
Eric is an assistant scoutmaster of Troop 33
in Laurel, Mississippi.
Jeff is an assistant scoutmaster in Omaha, Nebraska.
Alan is in Gurney, Illinois,
where he's an assistant scoutmaster for Troop 671..
And last but certainly not least,
Dan White is in Birmingham, Alabama,
and he is an assistant scoutmaster,
So thanks to everyone who came
and joined in the fun on the live chat.
Keep an eye on our Facebook feed and our Twitter feed
and you'll see announcements
for when we're going to have a live chat
at ScoutmasterCGcom,
Usually weekday mornings.
Come in and join one of the live chats.
It's great fun.
Check in and I'm always happy to hear from folks.
Hey, I've got great news.
Here's what's happening
with our trip to Condorsteg, Switzerland,
in July of 2016..
Now I've been feeling a lot of inquiries about this
and a lot of serious interest,
So let's go through the steps here.
Step one will be to review
the basic information about the trip
that is available at ScoutmasterCGcom.
If you go to the website,
you will see, prominently featured
in the menu right at the top of the website,
Condorsteg 2016..
Follow that link
and you'll get the basic information,
And I've also got the videos of my group's 2014 trip.
that'll give you a very good idea of what it's all about
And you can take that information
and begin to promote that with your folks
and put a group together.
Then we'll get you a group contract.
We've made our arrangements over in Switzerland
and we're going to need deposits no later
than September 15th of this year.
Now, as interest in the trip grows,
I've decided on setting a maximum of 45 participants.
I'll accept group reservations
on a first come, first serve basis
until we reach that maximum.
But, as I said, over the past couple of weeks,
there's been a lot of very serious interest in this,
So you don't want to wait,
And then, once we have a group contract figured out,
I'll share an activity guide that explains
all the activity options in greater detail
so that you and your group
can start discussing your options.
We'll get an activity schedule mapped out for you
and we'll be ready to go in July of 2016
to Kondersteg, Switzerland, the home
of Kondersteg International Scout Center.
Check out the trip once again at scoutmastercgcom.
Look for the link at the top of the page,
Get back in touch with me and we'll get your group signed up.
Hey, if you are a regular reader and listener
and if the resources at scoutmastercgcom
have helped you, you can return the favor
by becoming a backer.
Now, the funds we get from our backers
go towards the expenses of doing what I'm doing right now-
Producing and publishing blog posts
and podcasts and all that type of thing-
and keeping those resources freely accessible
to scouts all over the world.
It's really easy to do:
Go to scoutmastercgcom,
Look for the support link at the top of the page
And you can choose any level of support,
and some of them entitle you to premiums
like autographed copies of my books.
And I want to take a moment to personally thank
Malcolm Bliss, Trip Wycoff, Fred Glover,
David Shoup, Tom May and Brett Buck,
who have all become backers since the last podcast.
So go to scoutmastercgcom,
become a backer this week
and I'll be sure to thank you personally
during our next podcast.
And I want to reiterate: thank you so very much,
those of you who've become backers.
It's what keeps things moving
and makes all of this possible
This week. I have a few email questions to answer,
and that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
Cat came back. the very next day.
Cat came back. they thought it wasn't gonna,
But the cat came back,
it just wouldn't stay away.
Email that is: folks,
and here's an answer to one of your emails
and one of your email applications
you're gonna be able to use
for your next podcast,
And I'll see you in a bit.
Okay, so let's get started,
Get started.
Craig Dixon is the scoutmaster of Troops 682
in Poa, California,
And Craig wrote in saying
our camp and committee recently went
to a semi-annual permission slip
but they still want a form
for each scout for each trip.
get their paperwork done.
I want to help ease their pain,
but I'm not willing to set a rigid deadline,
like you can't go if your parent didn't give us
the form two weeks in advance.
In a way this affects our attendance,
which I'd like to see increase,
but we're having a lot of frustration with this.
What does your troop do and do you have any advice?
Well, Craig, you know paperwork and scouts
are kind of like oil and water. sometimes
Everybody I know have
and I know in our own troop
we're chasing papers all the time.
I think we'd like to maybe imagine
that there's some kind of foolproof method
or a way to design a system that's absolutely trouble-free,
where parents give us permission slips
exactly when we need them
or far in advance of when we need them.
but I gotta tell you
I doubt that that kind of system exists.
I've tried a number of different ideas
and things like that
and they work to a certain extent,
but when it comes down to it,
I think just once in a while
we run up against human nature
and we either roll with the punches or we punch back,
and if we punch back,
human nature counter punches us a little harder sometimes.
Now I know some folks would disagree,
but I think you're right.
We ought not to make scouts suffer
for things they can't control,
and they can't control what their parents are gonna do
when it comes to turning forms in right,
I bet every single troop
that's listening to the podcast right now
has a deadline for permission slips
that is rigidly flexible.
I know we do.
I think we want a permission slip,
as you suggested, like two weeks ahead.
but we also understand human nature
and people do what people do
and we'd rather have a scout go camping
than have them sit at home
because of a piece of paper.
So, understanding, Craig,
that this is kind of a non-answer answer,
I don't really have a solution for you.
Let's ask everybody out there
if what they do
as far as permission slips and deadlines
and things like that
are folks tell me about any successful practices
that you've had that seem to help out with this problem.
I'm sure everybody understands
exactly what the problem is.
Get in touch with me at Clark at scoutmastercgcom
and let me know if you've got a better answer for Craig.
I heard from Steve who said
I have three new scouts
who've just crossed over from Weebelos
and they are planning to attend summer camp.
Our camp is four and a half hours away.
I'm prepared for everything,
I think, except possible bouts of homesickness.
Do you have any articles you can suggest?
It would be greatly appreciated.
Steve, I do.
I have a couple of articles
about dealing with homesickness.
I won't go into every single detail here,
but hitting the high points.
Homesickness is not uncommon.
It's not a fair complete either.
just because a younger scout
is going to travel a distance
and go to a week of summer camp
doesn't immediately mean
that you would expect them to be homesick.
But naturally you want to be prepared if they are.
And you'll find, if you take a look at these articles-
and I'll have a link to them
in the post that contains this podcast-
that there are some strategies
that parents can use ahead of time
If they suspect their scout might be homesick
while they're away from home.
there's some strategies parents can apply ahead of time.
More about this particular thing
ends up in the hands of parents
than it does of scouts.
If you read these articles
I also have some very specific strategies for scouts
to employ if they encounter homesickness.
But with homesickness
an ounce of prevention is worth a pound of cure.
So you want to review that,
share that information with the parents of your scouts
and get them utilizing some of those strategies
that are explained in those articles
And that way you'll get to summer camp
and hopefully you won't have any bouts of homesickness
and everybody will have a great time.
Here's an interesting question from Bob.
Where do you put merit badges on the uniform without a sash?
Well, it's a pretty easy answer:
Go to the guide to awards and insignia
and I'll have a link to a PDF version of that
on the post that contains this podcast
And on page 31,
you will see an illustration of where merit badges
can go on the scout uniform.
It's on the right sleeve in what is called position four.
It's limited to six merit badges.
Now it'll only work on a long-sleeved uniform shirt,
Otherwise you'll have to get a sash.
But I hope that helps. Bob
Had a question from Greg Gotcher,
who is with Troop 372 in Waterford, Wisconsin,
And Greg said
I followed five weeblos into a Boy Scout Troop
and they've asked me to become the new scout master.
So into the volcano I go.
Well, good for you, Greg.
I'm really excited to see a transition
into a patrol based Troop.
Our first activity was this past weekend.
We were out camping with the Troop
and I was encouraged to see that it's somewhere
in the middle of adult lead and scout lead
and leaning closer to the scout lead side of things.
So I'm encouraged at taking over as a new scout master.
but I have a few questions about youth leadership.
Well, Greg, it sounds like you're having a great time.
Let's see if we can answer your questions.
So Greg's first question was:
is the senior patrol leader
and the assistant senior patrol leader part of a patrol?
Well, Greg, if you look in the scout master's handbook,
you'll see that the senior patrol leader
and assistant senior patrol leader are not patrol members.
Now, there's really not a definitive statement
that I could find when I was looking
about the senior patrol leader status,
But it does say this:
during his tenure as assistant senior patrol leader,
the scout is not a member of a patrol.
Greg goes on to ask:
are there any other positions of responsibility
that aren't part of a patrol?
Well, at, once again
looking in the scout master's handbook,
it says scouts serving
in any of the following troop positions.
then it goes on to list all of the positions
of responsibility within a troop,
like scribe, quarter, master, things like that-
will also continue to be active members of their patrols.
So other than the senior patrol leader
and assistant senior patrol leader,
everybody with a position of responsibility
is still an active member of their patrol.
Greg then asks:
so if the senior patrol leader
and assistant senior patrol leader
aren't members of a patrol,
are they not participating in any patrol activities?
And I think that depends, Greg.
If they're invited to participate
by the patrol, they certainly could,
But just the nature of things,
I wouldn't see them as being participants
on the same level as a member,
where they're expected to be there all the time
or to be a part of the patrol team.
They're gonna have their hands full
and they'll interact with the patrols
and the scouts a whole lot.
So whether or not they're a formal member or not,
I don't think that makes a great deal of difference.
And Greg brings up one very practical question.
So do the assistant senior patrol leader
and senior patrol leader can't by themselves
and do their own cooking and things like that?
Well, I think that they could if they wanted to.
I know that our tradition has been
that our senior patrol leader and his assistant camp
and cook along with the adults
seems to work out pretty good for us,
And the scouts who occupy those positions
of responsibility don't seem to mind.
I'd be curious to know if people
who do that any differently anywhere,
but one of my aims in that arrangement
is keeping them out of the patrol campsite
so that they don't become the default patrol leader.
And then the final question that Greg asked:
how do you see all this working
for a group of 16 boys?
Well, I think it's gonna work just fine.
Of the 16, two won't be members of a patrol,
So you have 14 scouts remaining.
That sounds like a planning
for two really good, strong patrols.
Now I say two, but you might end up with three,
You don't know.
Let's see what the scouts wanna work out
so far as setting up their patrols.
So when that question comes up,
don't answer that question for them.
Put that question to the patrol leaders council
and say: how do you wanna set this up
And see what they have to say.
We'll give them our best advice
on what makes a workable patrol and things like that.
Let's see what they come up with.
Let's see what answers they have.
So, Greg, I hope those answers helped you out a little bit,
and congratulations on jumping into the volcano here
with the rest of us.
Hey, if you have a question for me or a comment
and you'd like to get in touch, it's pretty easy to do,
And you're gonna find out how to do that in just a moment.
Well, thanks so much for listening to this 260th edition
of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch.
Read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there,
you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
You can join 4,000 other mobile scouters
who have the Scoutmaster CG app on their mobile devices,
and you can get the app at Google Play
or at the iTunes app store.
You can experience all the wonders of scoutmastercgcom,
such as they are, through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
Join the 8,200 folks who like Scoutmaster blog
on Facebook.
Tweet along with the chorus of over 1,200 tweeters
on Twitter.
Pin the poulter tooth in his pictures
proffered publicly with over 2,000 other
prolific pinners on Pinterest.
Watch us at ScoutmasterCG on YouTube
or join the nearly 500 odd folks
who form the exclusive Scoutmaster CG circle on Google+.
Now, if you can't face Facebook,
if Twitter makes you better,
if you have no interest in Pinterest,
if you don't put the? U in YouTube,
if you're a minus when it comes to Google+,
that's okay. Bunky,
Just zoom into the late 90s and send me an email.
You can get in touch with me, Clark Green,
with your comments and questions
at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmastercgcom.
It only remains for me to remind you
that all of this crazy business,
the Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast-
are not official publications of anyone in particular
other than myself.
We are not endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America
or any scouting organization for that matter.
It's just me talking into a microphone
and doing my best to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
And speaking of fun, here is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Pell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Oh, I thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.